des ateliers et les mène à temps la
focus orange les premières minutes du
filage sont laborieuses mais la nuit
tombée les comédiens amateurs se révèle
quelle belle fête de saint martin en ce
jour de septembre
1882 c'est le début de l'une des cinq
saynètes du spectacle sur scène les
habitants de luzoir d'amis ou encore de
la selle en r moi tous fiers de parler
de l'histoire de leur commune ça permet
nous même de connaître l'histoire de la
région du gâtinais et puis de connaître
des personnes qui ont vécu là bien avant
moi et qui connaissent leur histoire
donc il nous explique aussi l'histoire
des villages environnants on va beaucoup
dans des spectacles dans des grandes
villes dans les grands spectacles mais
des fois il ya des petits spectacles
comme ça qui sont faits avec un air
humoristique et moi je trouve qu'il ne
l'a fait revivre des petits villages à
la baguette de cet événement victoria
gas nos dans la vie est des
gestionnaires clients dans une mutuelle
c'est elle qui a écrit ce spectacle
avant partager beaucoup puis avec le co
vie de ces un petit peu éloigné puis ces
quelques années dernières années on
s'est un peu éloigné dans le village
quand même et là il ya une sorte de
rebond fallait que l'énergie ressortent
et et tous les habitants je vois ils
sont pleins d'énergie faut que ça
s'exprime quoi le dernier spectacle à
nous soit remonte à 18 ans alors le
maire est ravi de toute cette agitation
faire connaître justement la culture
l'histoire une autre tuile âgés que les
gens soient bénévoles comme celle qu'ils
s'engagent ça fait depuis trois mois il
répète
plusieurs fois par semaine donc c'est
vraiment formidable loire comptait 250
habitants en temps normal ils espèrent
attirer beaucoup plus de monde samedi
soir pour le jour j